the reason natran's delighted to partake
in the annual fiber of the home
conference each year
is the conference itself brings a unique
platform
that pulls together the key leadership
from the operator community
the main decision makers from the policy
and regulation side of the industry
as well as the leading technical minds
to interact together with the vendor
community
so that we can all decide how best
europe can go forward
with its broadband strategy if we look
forward over the next 10 to 15 years
right now we're in the ultra high
definition era of entertainment so it's
all 4k
tvs the consumer electronic
manufacturers are currently talking
about their next generation of tvs
and no i'm not talking about 8k i'm
talking about
16k screens that they're looking to
bring to the market think about the
bandwidth requirements that are going to
be needed for that it's critically
important that we accelerate the fiber
rollouts now across europe so that we
can maintain pace
and we don't stifle the ever increasing
pace of innovation